foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
because I feel like after you know third
grade I was like yeah dude this is I'm
over it
more like happiness in your life and
stuff bro who hurt you
married thank you very much what was his
name what was his name so check this out
this uh newest newest
I'm gonna let that one sit for a second
that was wrong yeah yeah he touched me
too here we go
this is great this is in Peru
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
on the receiving and yeah dude so the
cops are dressing up like superheroes so
this is this is legitimate no this is
legitimately uh operation Marvel it is a
drug oh my God that's sick the music was
was the [ __ ] chef's kiss but it's
kind of a dead getaway well it's like
now it is the first time I think is okay
right now that they've blasted this on
social media that it's it's over but
they could get Jesus because he wouldn't
know the reference if he heard the music
he's all like hey turn it down yeah
another [ __ ] so this is the actual uh
drug bust in Peru using you know uh both
the cloak of Marvel and Halloween uh in
times of trying to get closer to this
drug raid so they are actually dressing
up as characters they call this
operation Marvel and they would move
down the street pretending like it was
like a Halloween parade in order to get
closer to that house that spot that they
were gonna do a drug bust on that
they've been uh surveilling for quite
some time so obviously they were able to
get by surprise American guy here dude I
love it oh technically there way it
works that uh I don't really do I love
it your voice and everything was great
he's got to put us on game you know he's
got to let us know what to do but that
is crazy yeah so we had Spider-Man Thor
Captain America and Black Widow it was
not good oh man it looks like Catwoman
for sure absolutely I think they mixed
it I remember watching this video when I
was I was looking this up and the second
I actually get to that point where
they're smashing the door like oh [ __ ]
yeah dude that was pretty funny dude I
did not expect that we started what do
you think it was huh I thought they were
just like some weird Patrol like hey I'm
gonna roam the streets and then like
they're like high-fiving the kids right
yeah I thought it was a Halloween parade
yeah did they do that like in um Oregon
or something they had superheroes that
were actually like fighting crime and
[ __ ] yeah they did yeah but they weren't
like The Avengers they were just like
their own they made up their own
costumes they weren't doing [ __ ] drug
raids though no Captain America didn't
have a [ __ ] Sledgehammer like look at
this photo imagine you're the dude dude
sick ass bulge you're like
killer bulge man right there that's a
legitimate man put me in cups man well
there's no socks on that bulge yeah
Danny has a badge
right there man what happened I thought
you're my idol Spider-Man
these guys are fun that means the whole
that's a real SWAT team it wasn't like
you know actors so that means that one
cop lady had big old boobs yeah dude she
was black widow yeah she's the actual
black widow she looked like she killed
her husband like and I mean those
Latinos are vicious
that's so fun to have these superheroes
like in school instead of McGruff like
or what's that dog McGraw bring me those
guys [ __ ] cracking skulls and just
breaking windows and taking drugs you
guys are cool
maybe I would have still loved
superheroes if those guys came to my
school I'd be like [ __ ] yeah dude these
guys are legit I honestly thought it was
a birthday party I thought it was a
birthday party too yeah like maybe a
grand entrance you know because you saw
you saw the little like what do you what
do you call that doorway where it's just
I don't know the beads yeah well not the
beads but they had like some sort of I
don't know yeah like some fashion words
yeah and it said happy birthday or
something right those are Latinos trying
to be fancy said welcome Spider-Man
Inca Cola yeah
dude doesn't clarify the drugs but let's
just assume that uh it's uh it's a
cigarette it's right there illegal
cigarettes
my boy okay now please discover 3250
small packages containing cocaine paste
which is a basis extract of the coca
leaf and 287 bags of cocaine as well as
127 bags of marijuana marijuana yeah
cocaine yeah but the funniest part to me
are the costumes they look like you just
went to Target and you bought it from
the Halloween aisle yeah it looked weird
and they didn't have their size yeah
either way it worked you know what I'm
saying the speaker was the best part
because like they didn't really need to
do that right they they put that in the
front seat with them you know what I
mean they had to play the music they're
like almost like cumbersome speaker too
yeah or imagine like and it was
connected to an aux cord dude that guy
was left his phone walking around with
the speaker plus imagine the guy who
gets to be four but actually hold like a
hammer that he's gonna use you know the
Captain America takes the lead or looks
like he can drink you know what I mean
he looks like he's ready to drink has a
40. Spider-Man just not has no neck he's
like weird looking these guys are hurt
how is Spider-Man taller Spider-Man
doesn't even look like a teenager he
looks like a grown ass man she's
supposed to be black widow or Batgirl I
don't get it I don't know she's supposed
to be Black Widow but they have to wear
masks they didn't have her costume
protect their idea I mean it's kind of
obscure it's probably one of those
things that can play as both depends on
like choose your adventure dude but she
still has to show cleavage yeah she has
to uh it's used as a distraction yes
hello oh wow I didn't think about that
obviously you're paying attention to it
yeah I want to enter though so the
distraction is uh yeah they just all
look yeah yeah yeah yeah but this is a
good video weren't you Spiderman breaks
it down Black Widow comes out with the
boobs distracts them stuns them what is
that's the thing dude they break it they
open the doors everybody gets hypnotized
with the boobs oh and then they come in
and just like cartoons right around this
is my favorite video of the whole time
now dude can we watch it again I want to
watch it again
where they get out of the car details
that I didn't see before because the
speaker guy I left it the pep talk in
the beginning just like [ __ ] like an
actual movement
basically just enter The Establishment
look how legit they are look they're
serious he's on this shield and [ __ ]
his only job is to hold the speaker
look it's getting to the aux cord
and he turned it up he turns it up
[Music]
dude
which is the worst way to start a rage
it's like making noise we're coming
deal
get in there dude I love it
look at how pissed the guy is I just put
the windows inside of a bed
why break the wig I want to open the
door you [ __ ] door was unlocked my
daughter loves Thor [ __ ] dramatic
effect dude
I love how the girl the mom is just like
yeah
she's reading her Miranda Rights
[Music]
it is foreign
this is my favorite this is a great way
to start the day hey that's how it is
and I'm glad we have translation here
we've been misrepresenting you know in
this culture I believe our our source of
uh you know Latino news
and I just feel like it was
your uh Latinos he makes up Spanish
words he's apparently married to a
Mexican is that what it is oh I knew it
yeah and then he's got like this kid
who's 100 Chinese still somehow somehow
yeah he doesn't know that he's met 100
Chinese yeah he's in Mexican denial
fully identifies as Chinese damn dude I
asked him too I was like you know your
Mexican he goes nope I'm Chinese but he
wants to marry his mom who's Mexican it
used to be his Mexican cousin that he
wanted to marry because he didn't like
girls
who needs them right wow but now he's
evolved and he wants his mom but now he
wants to marry his mom he wants to marry
his mom yeah wow it doesn't Latino
we'll go to these ranches it gets weird
in there because he's freaking Ranchos
it gets a little weird in there I'm just
saying I'm like wait a minute you're his
I don't want to know I don't want to
know